After decades of silence, the CDC
is speaking up about America's
gun violence epidemic.
Gun violence in America is
a public health emergency.
Gun violence is a public health
issue.
And we need to start thinking of
this as a public health crisis.
Republican Congressman Jay Dickey
is infamous for a 1996
law prohibiting the CDC from using
federal funds to advocate for gun
control.
The Dickey Amendment.
The so-called Dickey Amendment.
Remember the Dickey Amendment, which
has effectively kept the CDC from
studying gun violence?
What inspired the Dickey Amendment
was a blockbuster 1993 CDC-funded
study, which claimed to show that
owning guns made Americans
overwhelmingly less safe.
Having a gun in your home not
only doesn't protect you,
but it puts your family at risk.
According to a recent film published
by The New York Times, the NRA
lobbied for the Dickey Amendment
because the 1993 study made
an overwhelming case against gun
ownership, and it wanted to stop the
CDC from ever backing studies
of this sort again.
And the NRA didn't think
that that would be good for
business.
And this really spurred
them on to attack us with much
greater fury.
The problem with this story is that
the 1993 study doesn't actually
show what its proponents claim.
It had serious statistical problems
that stemmed from its approach to
the topic of gun violence,
underscoring why the Dickey
Amendment was good policy.
A public health agency isn't
well-suited to analyzing social
science issues of this sort.
This is not serious research
designed to improve individual
decisions or social policy.
It's scientific crap.
It is used to camouflage arguments
no one would take seriously if they
were presented clearly.
Statistician Aaron Brown has taught
at NYU and the University of
California at San Diego.
He's a columnist for Bloomberg and
an expert on risk management.
The initial conception of this study
is that a gun is like a pathogen in
your home that causes homicide
in unspecified ways.
A gun is like a homicide virus.
Brown points out that unlike with
death from disease, when a gun
kills someone in a home, the
surrounding circumstances are highly
relevant.
The researchers count all deaths
equal to whether the homeowner or
her family or a homicidal
home invader.
Someone not blinded by disease
control thinking would focus on how
these guns were used for
self-defense, suicide, accidental
injury, domestic violence, or seen
by mechanically used against the
owner.
This could be useful information for
someone weighing the benefits and
risks of keeping a gun in the house.
A major flaw in the study is that it
attributes homicides to the presence
of guns in the home.
Even if a gun wasn't involved.
In fact, the majority of the
homicides don't have a gun at all.
And if a gun was involved, the
researchers don't bother to ask if
it was to homeowner's gun.
The risk was 200%
greater that someone in your
family would be shot and killed with
a gun and the risk that
someone in your home would commit
suicide with the gun was
five times greater.
The 400% increase
in risk.
That may be what Rosenberg would
have liked the study to find, but
it did not.
It did find that people living in
homes with guns were murdered in
their homes more frequently than
people living in similar houses
without guns.
But only 25% more frequently,
not 200% or five times.
And far more dangerous than guns
were living in a gated community,
living alone or renting.
Having been in trouble for drinking
at work, made you 20 times more
likely to be murdered in your home.
The politicized nature of the study
is shown by ignoring the big risks
it found and highlighting one of the
smallest.
But what this really shows is the
methodology is absurd.
No one would take it seriously if
we applied it to rent in gated
communities and no one should take
it seriously applied to guns.
Brown says that the authors also
failed to establish convincingly
that the 25% finding isn't
the result of random chance.
It is notoriously easy to
find 25% or 50%
effects of the kind shown in this
paper.
For any effect you want.
The study considered 388 people
murdered at homes and found that 174
of them had owned guns.
They matched them with 388 similar
people who were not murdered, 138
of whom owned guns.
The first question you might ask is
whether this difference could be the
result of random chance
if gun ownership has no effect
on your chance of getting murdered
at home.
Statisticians call this the
significance of the study.
By arbitrary convention.
Most journals will accept
publications of the significance
as less than 5%.
That is if there is less than one
chance in 20 years or just random
variation.
The authors compute a 4%
significance for the 174
murder victims with guns.
But this calculation assumes all
data is measured without error,
that their sampling is perfectly
random, and that all important
control variables are included.
Those assumptions are never met
exactly in any real study,
and this study is very far from
ideal.
A rough rule of thumb used by many
practicing statisticians
is to be taken seriously
and observational after the fact.
Study like this needs to find
a 3-to-1 effect. That is three times as many gun owners murdered in their homes as similar non-gun owners, regardless of idealized statistical calculation.
Brown says that when studying topics
like gun violence that are fully
determined by human behavior,
it's necessary to take a
multidisciplinary approach,
a requirement that may be lost on
public health scientists trained to
study disease.
You fight an epidemic by trying to
eradicate a pathogen.
So the only solution to a gun
violence epidemic is to get rid of
guns.
But violence is a more complex
social problem than disease.
Violence can do good as well as
harm, and guns can protect
as well as kill.
In an epidemic, all of this are
equal and all are bad,
but some gun deaths are good,
the result of legitimate
self-defense or law enforcement.
And some are worse than others.
Innocent bystanders, for example,
versus suicide or armed gang members
trying to kill each other.
Gun control policy should be
informed by criminologists,
sociologists, psychologists,
political scientists, legal experts,
historians, and others.
All of these fields have built up
extensive knowledge about guns and
violence.
Yet this study and most public
health gun control research cites
only other public health
researchers.
That NRA strategy
of hyperpolarizing the people
worked out well for them,
but it had devastating
consequences in terms of continuing
gun deaths.
The Times video asserts that not
enough research has been done on the
causes of gun violence and that
Dickey is partly to blame.
The real issue, Brown says, is
quality, not quantity.
The Dickey Amendment did not stop
gun control research.
The RAND Corporation tabulated
28,000 recent papers
and gun control proposals.
The problem is quality.
Only 123 of those papers
met minimal statistical standards.
He said, "isn't it true that
you really want to get rid
of all guns?" And I
felt, How dare him?
This guy is really bad.
Worse than not understanding.
He doesn't care.
Jay Dickey and I, at that point,
were really kind of mortal enemies.
The film is structured around the
story of an improbable friendship.
In the 1990s, Congressman Dickey
and Mark Rosenberg, then director of
the CDC's National Center for Injury
Prevention and Control, went from
adversaries to best friends.
We started talking, and we actually
started to trust each other,
and we started to like each other.
And over the years, that
developed into an incredible
friendship.
Rosenberg convinces him to change
his mind and repent.
He is the former self-described NRA
point person and now is a strong
supporter of research.
I think the CDC should do the
gun research that relates
to gun violence.
You're the guy.
It's your bill.
Feel different now than I did
before.
Dickey, who died of Parkinson's in
2017, may have come
to regret pushing for the amendment
that bears his name, but he remained
concerned about the 1993
study, which would have complicated
the New York Times narrative in
which the filmmakers left out.
The New York Times film uses this
clip.
What changed?
How did you have the change of
heart?
Well, I just think it's it's
just the weight of all of the
incidents that have occurred.
And that is that the kids and
the innocent people who are being
killed deserve our
attention.
What the filmmakers cut out was
Dickey's ongoing concerns about the
1993 study and how it was
carried out.
We wanted research
done for gun
violence, and that's what the
money was paid for.
But we found out as we went along
that not only was the research
being done just to support gun
control, but we weren't even
given access to what the collected
data was.
So it was it was clear
that we needed to do something to
stop what was being done.
That's exactly correct.
Research funded by the CDC on gun
violence is unscientific from the
start.
Guns are not a pathogen and
violence is not a disease to be
controlled.
What is needed is not propagandistic
films or sloppy research.
It's cross-disciplinary research on
what drives human beings to
violence, whether with a gun or not.
Everything we have seen on this
issue from the CDC indicates to
me that they are the wrong
organization to manage this
research.